et maintenant Madame Christine
bonfantido ça pour le groupe les
républicains
vous annonciez avec fierté une baisse de
la délinquance je vous cite une baisse
timide mais une baisse quand même hier
tomber les chiffres de la délinquance
dans notre département
violence sexuelle plus 11%. cousez bien
sûr plus 14 %. cambriolage plus
11%, vol de véhicule plus 9% avec 879
victimes de crimes en 2022 nous sommes
désormais face au niveau le plus élevé
depuis 30 ans
ces chiffres ne proviennent ni de Libé
ni de l'humanité ce sont les chiffres
officiels de votre ministère est nul ne
pourra dans les contester mais derrière
ces chiffres il y a des réalités il y a
des Françaises et des Français qui
vivent dans la peur
les sécurité est devenue une triste
réalité qui n'a cessé de croître pendant
les quinquennats d'Emmanuel Macron mon
département de Lot-et-Garonne à l'image
de tous les départements souffrent
cruellement de cette politique le
quotidien de nos forces de l'ordre est
extrêmement difficile manque de moyenne
humain et de matériel découragement le
mot est faible absence de réponse pénale
des voyous qui font la loi partout et
qui n'ont peur de rien ni de personnes
oui les policiers et les gendarmes se
font ce qu'ils peuvent mais encore
faudrait-il des condamnations fortes
vous ne pouvez pas sans cesse renvoyer
la faute sur vos prédécesseurs
l'insécurité monsieur le ministre n'est
pas une fatalité elle est le résultat de
manque de courage et d'une absence de
volonté politique monsieur le ministre
face à cette délinquance explosive le
gouvernement est-il vraiment en capacité
de protéger les Français
merci
pour vos répondre la parole est à
Monsieur Gérald Darmanin ministre de
l'intérieur des Outre-mer ah pardon
alors un monsieur le garde des sceaux
merci merci monsieur le président madame
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice puisque la justice selon vous
n'est pas au rendez-vous de ces
obligations cette question à l'origine
fléchée pour le ministre de l'Intérieur
je vais me faire un plaisir d'y répondre
d'abord voyez-vous en deux minutes c'est
une gageure que d'évoquer ces questions
de la délinquance
quelle est la part dans l'augmentation
ou éventuellement la diminution de
certaines infractions du confinement
quelle est la part de libération de la
parole dans les violences intra
familiales plus de force de l'ordre
c'est aussi plus de fées constater sur
le voie publique et d'une certaine façon
une augmentation de la délinquance je me
permets de vous le dire les escroqueries
on en a davantage mais nous avons mis en
place une plateforme Thésée qui permet
de mieux les appréhender la justice
madame la sénatrice c'est durant cette
période un taux de poursuite de plus de
de plus pardon 13%. et les peines en
matière correctionnelles entre 2017 et
2022 sont passés en moyenne peine ferme
de 6,7 mois à 8,3 mois donc la justice
n'est pas laxiste elle est au
rendez-vous des obligations qui sont les
siennes et parler une fois encore en
deux minutes de la délinquance
franchement c'est une gageure ça mérite
de plus amples explications
de reconnaître que le Président de la
République est davantage collectionneur
que joueurs
[Applaudissements]
la parole